I was chasing him, the poor soul who saw me.
He was wearing a thick, red winter coat and
glasses, climbing up the side of the mountain
with a sharp little tool.
If I had known he was coming, I would have
run.
Of course, I would have run.
But it was already too late.
The second he saw me, saw my horrible, ugly
face, it was already over.
I felt all those familiar feelings bubble
up.
I knew, as well as I knew anything in life,
that I would need to kill him.
My name...
Well, I don’t know my name.
Not really.
I think I had one once, a long, long time
ago.
I don’t think I always looked like this
- like this big, ugly monster.
But who can say?
Those memories were blown away like a snowdrift.
Life - this life, at least - has never been
easy for me.
I don’t like hurting people.
But at least, up there in the mountains, people
didn’t see me that often.
How could I know about the strange men who
would come for me?
How could I possibly know that it was all
going to get so much worse?
The poor man in the red coat who saw me tried
his best to run.
I think my crying frightened him.
I wish my mouth could make words - If it could,
I would have told him how sorry I was.
But it didn’t matter anymore.
I kept moving towards him, like I was being
pulled along by some invisible leash in his
direction.
I tried to stop.
I tried to think really hard, to focus.
I kept telling myself, “No, not this time.
You’re better than this.
You can let this one go.”
But before the sentence is even fully formed
in my mind, I’m already on top of him.
I look down and see his terrified face, tears
frozen on his cheeks.
Eyes wide with horror you can’t even begin
to describe - If you haven’t seen my face.
He was still looking at me.
It hurt that he was looking at me.
I leaned in and opened my mouth, wide enough
to swallow him whole.
Soon enough, there was nothing left of the
man in the red coat, and I was alone again.
All I could think to do was sit there on the
freezing mountainside and weep.
Why did I keep doing this?
Why couldn’t I stop myself?
I’d asked myself these questions again and
again, but I never got an answer.
It felt like I knew myself a little less every
single day.
Sometime later - I don’t know how many days,
weeks, or months - two huge, black, noisy
creatures came towards me out of the sky.
The second I saw them, I turned and started
moving away.
I couldn’t let those creatures see me.
I knew something terrible would happen if
they did.
It was best just to move away, let them leave
me alone.
Nobody had to die.
What I didn’t know was that I was the reason
they were there.
The two flying black creatures landed on the
mountain behind me, and groups of people climbed
out, carrying strange objects I didn’t recognize.
I huddled myself away in a corner as one of
the men came towards me.
I was so afraid I couldn’t stop myself from
crying.
I didn’t have the words - I couldn’t tell
them how much danger they were in.
Couldn’t tell them that I didn’t want
to hurt them, that they should just leave
me here.
But it was already too late.
One of the strange men walked right in front
of me, and saw my face.
He said, “Jesus, this thing is one ugly—“
I started screaming.
I couldn’t stop myself.
My head started going fuzzy and my heart hurt.
The man who’d seen my face was already backing
away, knowing just a few seconds too late
that he’d made an awful mistake.
It wouldn’t save him now.
Nothing could save him.
I tried to stop myself, but trying hurt.
It just made me scream louder.
I turned and lunged at him, but that made
things worse: Now, so many of the others had
seen my face, too.
With fat, wet tears rolling down my cheeks,
I knew that I would have to destroy them all
- even though I didn’t want to.
But this time, they fought back.
I suddenly heard all these horrible loud noises
all around me, and felt white-hot pain all
over my body.
They were shooting at me, both with the objects
they held, and other, even larger weapons
attached to their strange, flying vehicles.
This made my confusion and anger even worse.
I went berserk, jumping at them and attacking
them with my claws and teeth.
They may have been able to hurt me more than
ordinary people, but they were just as easy
to destroy as anyone.
Not that it made me feel any less terrible
for doing it, even though they attacked me
first.
Who were these strange, aggressive people?
And why had they come here to attack me?
Soon enough, I’d destroyed all the ones
who had seen my face.
There was nothing left to do but just sit
there and weep again.
I felt so terrible about everything I’d
done to them.
It was a pain deep, deep in my chest.
But then, suddenly, everything went black,
and a sack was pulled over my head.
I couldn’t see who did it, and I’m glad
I didn’t.
More importantly, they didn’t see me.
I think after that, they bundled me onto one
of their flying vehicles and took me away.
I had no idea where I’d end up next.
All I could do was stand there with a bag
over my head, and cry.
Still blinded, and after a long period of
flying through the air, I was pulled out of
the vehicle and dragged away somewhere.
I felt grateful that I didn’t know.
If I was here to be punished, it was probably
what I deserved.
Soon enough, I was brought into a room where
a bunch of strangers were looking at me.
I’d later learn that one of these strangers
was called Dr. Dan.
And Dr. Dan seemed very interested in what
had happened back on the mountain.
The one who put the bag over my head was talking
to Dr. Dan.
He said, “That thing killed all of my men.
Tore through them like tissue paper.
Our heavy artillery barely slowed it down,
and it regenerated any damage it sustained
almost immediately.”
“Fascinating,” Dr. Dan said.
“And yet it seems so docile now.
Why?
What activated its rage state during the confrontation?”
“Connors looked at its face.
That’s when it went ballistic.”
Hearing the story told again, I started to
weep.
It was true; everything they were saying was
true.
I killed all those poor people, even though
I couldn’t help it.
There was no place for me in this world, if
all I could do was hurt people.
I’d be better off not existing at all.
Everything was a bit of a blur after that.
The next time the bag was removed, I was in
some kind of room.
A perfect cube that clanked and clunked every
time I moved around it.
No windows, no doors.
Probably for the best.
All I could do was pace around this little
cube and wait, wait until Dr. Dan was ready
to conduct more of his tests.
I’d never felt more empty and alone, but
at least I couldn’t hurt anyone here.
Thank heavens for small mercies.
Sometime later, I was bagged again and taken
out of the cube.
I don’t know where they took me, but suddenly,
I felt that terrible feeling again.
Knowing that someone out there had seen my
awful, ugly face.
Knowing that, no matter what I really wanted
to do, I had to destroy them.
It was the only way.
But how had they even seen my face while I
was wearing the bag?
It didn’t make sense.
None of it made any sense.
I felt the strong tug of the invisible leash
again.
Pulling me towards the one who’d seen me.
I screamed and roared and waited and tore
off the bag.
I started galloping across the land in front
of me, all barren and empty, until I reached
the water.
I was right next to the ocean.
I leaped in and started diving.
Getting deeper, deeper, deeper.
Eventually, I found a strange metal sphere.
Somehow, I just knew the one who had seen
my face was somewhere in there.
I tore it open and found him, a man in an
orange jumpsuit.
He screamed as water filled his lungs.
Moments later, he was gone.
I swam back to shore, tears dissolving in
the ocean, where the strange men bagged me
again, and I was back in the cube.
It was a moment of calm.
Soon, things were going to get so much worse.
That terrible day, it happened a lot like
last time.
The time next to the ocean.
I was inside my cube when I felt that terrible
feeling, the sensation of being looked at.
This time, I somehow sensed that the one who
saw me was even further away.
I said to myself, this time, I’d resist.
I’d stop myself.
Nobody would be hurt.
But resisting the pull hurt me even more.
All I could do was wait and howl in terrible
pain, as I heard people panicking and scrambling
outside the walls of my room.
Soon enough, it was too late.
I couldn’t stop myself.
I needed to find the one who saw me and destroy
them.
The walls gave way like wet sand as I tore
through them.
There were so many people in white coats standing
around the room.
A terrible-smelling gas that burned my throat
flooded the room, killing most of the people
around me.
But as always, I survived, and I started running,
feeling the pull towards the person who saw
my face.
I busted through walls and galloped across
the ground, feeling the miles tick by each
second.
I could hear the distant hum of more of those
flying vehicles in the air behind me, but
it didn’t matter.
None of it mattered.
All that mattered was finding the one who
saw me and wiping them off the face of the
earth, no matter how awful it made me feel
inside.
Soon, I arrived at a town where everyone was
gathered in the center.
They all turned and looked at me, and I could
feel the rage rising to a fever pitch.
There were so many of them, all those poor
people.
And not long after, more people with guns
arrived, wearing strangle goggles.
They all looked at my face too.
I couldn’t help it.
I’m so sorry.
I just couldn’t help it.
I try not to think about how many people I
killed that day, but soon enough, a bag was
placed back over my head, and I was dragged
back to my room - which they’d rebuilt while
I was gone.
I remained in there for a long time, just
weeping, consumed by my own seemingly endless
sadness.
Until one day, sometime later, I was dragged
out of my room and taken to another chamber.
I could hear something that wasn’t human
breathing when they pulled the bag off of
my head.
I was standing across from a monster, staring
right at my face.
A huge, terrible reptile, with a thick hide
and giant claws and teeth.
It hissed when it saw me.
It was happening again.
The pain started; I was weeping and wailing.
Was this all my life would ever be?
A mix of silence and violence?
Only existing to hurt others and be sad, hurt,
and alone, unable to even control my own actions?
What kind of a life is that, if you can even
call it a life?
The monster hissed and said, “You are disgussssting.”
Silently, I agreed.
Now go check out “SCP-096 - The Shy Guy”
and “SCP-096 VS SCP-343” for more tragic
tales of the Shy Guy!